and with it with re - with my fingers
are it take you to make me oh yeah Jews
are easy to the Irish you can't give us
a phone well Koreans are stubborn you
know why you're the Irish
I don't probably a stubbornness I'm
gonna say I don't hang out with enough
Koreans to know and yeah your fault that
I don't like quick rage you say just
Koreans because I would say the whole
continent especially I guess even
compared to like a convenience store
yeah they freaked out on you yeah but
their rage is very quick and I go from
speaking speaking speaking 100 rate what
hundred percent screaming and then he
comes down pretty quickly you come down
quickly I do but when it comes to and
it's I don't know what it is but when it
comes to and and and this is when it
comes to my stage time or being a
stand-up course your lively it's it's
literally everything from me back then
and any perceived danger to it was
automatically something that I had to
kill right or fight off I remember being
like I would do the same thing right
like like like it of it if I was at an
open mic and I signed up and then I
would they come up to me yeah you're not
going up because we have too many people
but all everyone else has signed up yeah
but you know I don't know you so you
know and in my head you would be not
just you know oh I'll just let it go it
was like I remember you I remember you
and I'm gonna get you but that's the oh
no other circumstances am I like that in
but when it comes to like comp like if I
hear out in comic bad-mouth me to a club
owner or something like oh that's awful
right it would it would it would
generate you mean a resentment and like
you're [ __ ] with my livelihood and
it's just it's just and I perceived
Eleanor and Corey and Freddie for a long
time like that that they were people
that I had to fight you know and
and some of my behavior was in
retrospect appalling but am I admitted
to admit do I do ice I'm sorry admit it
you know I I feel like I'm getting
better in every area of my life even
like when I'm you know you know when I
was on MADtv and I used to [ __ ] in
people's offices or I'm sorry what yeah
or are you still [ __ ] falls apart you
know I mean in people's faces and just
get in trouble I crashed the company car
when I was on that day I would just do
things and I would act out you know in a
like I'm a rebellious comic and you
can't tell me what to do kind of a thing
okay and now it's 100% the opposite like
I show up on time I listen to you know I
mean I you know if they want me to stay
as long as I can see how the years have
changed me and I also know that not one
event is gonna ruin me or you me back in
the day you thought that one bet oh my
god yeah was gonna take you down or yeah
there goes my future you know whereas
now I know oh that guy doesn't like me
it's fine I mean I've never been to
Montreal right and so you know in my
head I mean but I've done other things
you know like you know um and I don't
one thing isn't going to destroy me one
thing is not gonna make me either
it's accumulation of just me staying in
it and just constantly you know
auditioning and going up and just being
present you know maybe not thinking
everybody's out to get you yeah also you
know that's a very narcissistic trait to
think everybody not to get yeah you're
still very focused on yourself and you
think that people are taking the time to
bother to speak about you to think about
you to even like when you audition say
for instance and you're like that was
the worst audition ever I can never see
that person again
your head you're thinking that that
person is gonna remember you that person
is not going to remember yeah so I have
actually seen people that I have
auditioned for and there's acts so cool
but in my head I'm like oh I'm out you
know it's yeah I mean I have problems
but we you know a lot of people do that
I know people don't like me talking
about showbiz and all that stuff